[Music]
8 news now is on your side we warned you
last week about the top Black Friday
holiday shopping scams all right so
tonight we're going to take a look at
some of the end of the year scams when
it comes to charitable giving and also
how you can be alerted about scams and
what steps to take if you become a
victim Kirsten Joyce reports
plenty of scammers out there trying to
cash in on people's Goodwill trying to
get their hands on the money the
Charities are working to pull in before
the end of the year aarp's director of
fraud prevention programs Kathy Stokes
this has reached a crisis level in this
country Stokes encourages everyone to do
their research on Charities before
donating here are the websites to go to
don't just respond with your heart and
your wallet go online check out the
charity at give.org or charitywatch.org
make sure the money that you're putting
into that charity is actually going to
that charitable cause Stokes Works to
educate adults on the risk that fraud
represents but it's not only to members
anyone can sign up for the Network's
Watchdog alert by email or text to
receive information about scams she and
her team have created a new victim
support program to end the use of gift
cards in fraud a recent survey shows
nearly 70 percent of consumers plan to
buy gift cards for someone this season
that same survey found one in four
consumers has received a gift card with
no value on it here's what she says you
need to do check the balance as soon as
you receive a card take a picture of it
so you have proof that there is value on
it and use it sooner than later
now if you've been scammed you need to
call your bank right away you can also
get help on the next steps to take by
calling the aarp's fraud Network hotline
we've got that number for you in the
bottom of the screen it's
877-908-3360. now they've got trained
volunteers to help you it's free and you
don't need to be a member now